According
to the American Tribune,
Green Party candidate and
president-no-so-elect Jill Stein
has been arrested
for embezzling funds
from her election recount money
to throw a massive
marijuana-themed party
-in California, which is Spanish
for "marijuana." -(laughter)
Her guest list allegedly
included some of the quote,
"richest liberals
in Los Angeles,"
also know
as the @midnight writers.
-No.
-(laughter)
So, comedians,
what are some things
you might overhear
at Jill Stein's pot party?
(laughter)
Never had someone buzz in
for someone else before.
-Kristen Schaal.
-Thank you so much.
Uh, I need to get higher
so that I can forget
that a toke for Stein
is a toke for Trump!
-HARDWICK: All right.
-(laughter)
-Points for that. Rich Fulcher.
-(applause and cheering)
Uh, which one is Jill Stein?
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
-Points.
-Noah Fielding.
-I like how Rich's stoned voice
is the same as his normal voice.
It's the same
as his regular voice.
-Shut up! Just shut up!
-Oh, my God.
That scene was... That scene was
just called "Rich Fulcher..."
I knew you'd embarrass me.
HARDWICK: That scene was just
called "Rich Fulcher
-at Jill Stein's pot party,"
though... -(laughter)
-Even though they've both been,
do I still need to buzz? -Yeah.
-You can, or you don't have to?
-Yeah?
Oh, (bleep).
-I'm gonna do an impression
of Rich Fulcher. -Please.
(slowly, in strained voice): "I
hope Donald Trump gets in there.
Then we can fashion a bong out
of his hair."